did you
see the match last night
i saw most of it and i've got to say
just like the rest of the country i was
just absolutely thrilled to see what
emma had done i mean what what a
phenomenal performance but what also
you're just a huge inspiration to all of
us
wasn't it um extraordinary not to extend
this the
i thought i thought the eloquence of the
two young women afterwards and their
their graciousness to each other to each
other should be a lesson to politics
shouldn't it
it's a lesson to us all i mean to to go
through that and both with the that
desire to win but whatever the result
how they sort of come together they
embrace each other afterwards i think
there's lessons there for all of us
all right well let's um let's talk about
the uh hostilities um
open this morning with uh an
investigation by a newspaper into your
colleague preeti patel who it is alleged
has broken the lobbying rules again
is she becoming
a liability to your government
no not at all i mean i i've done that
job of being home secretary i know just
how
difficult a job it is and i think she's
been doing really well over the last
couple of years and it's it certainly is
one of the most challenging jobs in
government and uh i remember when i had
that job when you're waking up almost
every day and finding there's something
going on that that's your is something
to do with the home office and it's it's
a big job and i think she's doing a good
job
yeah but um she could probably do
without not to extend the tennis
metaphor too much without yet more
unforced errors by meeting people she
ordered to be meeting look i i haven't
seen that report so i'm not sure uh what
you're referring to but
i i think that as i say it's a it's a
really tough job and she's doing really
well there's so many things that she's
already done with the legislation that's
been put forward but i also know as home
secretary you also do a huge amount that
never gets into the public car because
it's not something you can ever talk
about publicly and
and i think it's obvious to me having
done that job that she's carrying out
that part of the work here the stuff
that's never in the public you know
incredibly well
okay let's talk about how you're doing
your job can we please expect that there
will be no need for pcr tests when we
travel in the near future
well
trevor if i may just uh sort of set out
our plans uh for the future and i will
respond to that question as well you
know that we're entering autumn and
winter it's something that covered other
viruses you know usually like the prime
minister this week will be setting out
our plans to manage covid over the
coming few months and in that we'll be
making it clear that first of all our
vaccine program is working it's been
phenomenally successful we now got
over 80 percent of people over the age
of 16 you know double vaccinated some 90
at least uh having one jab and it's been
fantastic in reducing the rate of
hospitalization you know something we
all wanted to see alongside that where
it's been complemented by your fantastic
new treatments a juggernaut of a testing
regime and uh also our surveillance
program probably the one of the best in
the world so you know we've got a huge
number of defenses of course we still
want to remain uh very cautious and
there are some things that when it comes
to travel for example there are some
rules that are going to have to remain
in place but the pcr
test test that's required upon your
return to uk from certain countries look
i want to try and get rid of that as
soon as i possibly can i'm not going to
make that decision uh right now but i've
already asked officials that the moment
we can let's get rid of these kind of
intrusions the cost that generates for
families particularly families just
trying to go out on holiday you know we
shouldn't be keeping anything like that
in place for a second longer than is
absolutely necessary okay so um the
tests gone asap what about vaccines for
12 to 15 year olds also asap
well i i think your your viewers will
know that we have been looking at that
i'm not in a position to make a final
decision on it i've received advice a
week or so ago from the jcvi our
committee of experts uh their advice uh
was that
that i should ask the these chief
medical officers of the uk the four
chief officers in the uk to to take a
look at not just the the health aspects
of vaccination but whether there were
any broader reasons that it might be in
the welfare of children and that's what
i've done and they need to be given the
time to look at this and i'll wait to
see what they have to say have they
given when will they give you their
advice
i'm not going to push them they need to
take their time it's it's independent
advice as it as it should be they need
to take their time i don't think they'll
be taking uh you know that much longer
um but in the meantime i have uh asked
the department to work with schools the
school vaccination teams to start
preparing you know just in case uh we
have a situation where their advice is
to recommend it and then if that if the
government accepts that then i just want
to be able to go ahead with it
isn't this a little bit
of a relaxed approach to something that
is really rather urgent we're already
seeing cases spiking in scotland uh
after schools opened there a few weeks
ago and actually
you're saying that we're focusing on the
vaccine you said that this morning as a
first line of defense but actually we're
seeing warning signs from elsewhere in
the world israel for example that the
effectiveness of the vaccine
might be waning
are you being a bit complacent about the
situation
no not at all i think that just let's
deal with
the vaccinations they're both
potentially for children but also
potentially boosters and i'll come on to
that the
for vaccinating children if we are to
make such a decision
it has to be led by the experts we have
to listen to expert opinion now as i've
said the jcvi have already looked at
this they made a recommendation to me to
pass it
to have another look from a different
aspect from other medical experts and
that's the right way to do it and i
think it's fair to say that you know
people adults are going to be naturally
more hesitant about vaccinating their
children and they worry about
vaccinating themselves that's perfectly
understandable that's true the world
over so if we're going to do this it has
to be done properly and it must not be
rushed when it comes
soon
well
hopefully soon and as i say
in anticipation of uh the final advice
you know i want to be ready and that's
why the system is getting ready for this
but can i also just turn to boosters
because you talked about waning immunity
we now of course do know more about this
virus and vaccination than we ever knew
before there is evidence of waning
immunity particularly in older people uh
more vulnerable people and we're already
taking action on that so for example
just a week ago i announced that those
people that are immuno suppressed you
know that they that should get a third
uh jab not as part of their primary
treatment that has already started and
in terms of a general booster program we
have asked the jcvi to look into this
they gave me interim advice a month or
so ago where they supported this but
they said they wanted to do some further
work we give them the time to do that
work but i believe we will be able to
start our booster program subject to
their final advice on schedule this
month
good okay now um
when the prime minister speaks to us
this week about his program for the
autumn and winter will that include
vaccine passports of the kind that the
scots have already decided they will
have that is to say
when i go clubbing will i need to have a
vaccine passport
well trevor i know you like clubbing i
know why this is so
important to you so
let me answer your question then look i
think if we went down the road of
vaccine passports or vaccine
certification as it's sometimes called
that's a big decision for any government
to make we have been looking at that
we've been open about that instinctively
you know i don't like the idea at all of
people having to let's say present
papers uh to do you know basic things so
if we do that the there it has to be
something uh that is looked at very
carefully and something that we believe
that has to be done with no alternative
with the vaccination rates
with the vaccination rates rising for
example with 16 and 17 year olds we only
started uh just last month now over 50
percent of 16 17 year olds are already
uh vaccinated you know i think we need
to take that into account and make a
final decision but i hope we can avoid
it
well you say you hope you can avoid it
but
this is a precautionary issue i mean
uh
vaccine passports
are proposed because
they need we need to protect
people well coming back to the clubs
people like myself and michael globe uh
gov who are in and out of clubs every
week we need to protect people
are you ruling it out or is it still on
the table
look i am not i'm not here today to to
rule that out we haven't made a final
decision at as a government we have been
looking at it we've been very open about
that but i as i've said that i think if
we did something like that it has to be
supported by the evidence and it has to
be something that is absolutely
absolutely necessary with no alternative
so you know as i say i hope we can avoid
it
what is the evidence telling you about
the big danger this winter is it
more covered delta variant is it a new
variant or is it conventional flu what
is the evidence telling you that we need
to be most concerned about
well
winter autumn
it's not just covid that likes that part
of the year it's other viruses too and
you've just mentioned another really
important uh thing that we've got to
prepare for and uh that is flu i've
already mentioned the the preparations
for boosters and i think that's going to
be an important part of our defense but
when it comes to flu what we've been
planning in the past few weeks is the
biggest flu vaccination program this
country has ever seen why am i concerned
about that because last year we didn't
have much flu because of all the other
controls that were in place and that
means just is a lot less immunity around
to flu than than normal and we know that
in some years in a bad flu year just how
terrible it can be so alongside our
continuing
covert vaccine program we're going to
have our biggest ever flu program and i
would say to those people listening that
certainly those that over 50 getting
your flu jab is going to be as important
as having your kobe jab all right let's
talk about the other big announcement of
last week when you broke your manifesto
pledge in order to introduce a new
health and social care levy a new tax
um you've asked us to believe that the
12 million billion
that you're going to raise each year for
the next three years will eventually go
into social care um when you're in
banking would you say to a customer i've
just raised the interest rate on your
loan but don't worry trust me uh would
you uh give me your mortgage to look
after um why would we trust
what you say
after you've broken not one but two
manifesto pledges
well first can i just turn to the
manifesto pledges since you started uh
with that you're right we made we made a
commitment that we wouldn't raise
certain taxes and that included national
insurance now we had an option given the
global pandemic we had an option we
could doggedly sort of stick to that
manifesto commitment and say look you
know what we know there's a global
pandemic we know that there's
unprecedented strain on our health and
social care systems they need more
support but we're going to ignore that
because we've got a manifesto commitment
or we could have said we're going to do
the responsible thing and the
circumstances have changed i think it's
no exaggeration to say that no one had
predicted this this pandemic and that it
has changed you know so many things and
we could respond to that in a
responsible way and that's what we've
done and
i wasn't prepared to see as the health
secretary for example with the nhs with
the growth that we were seeing in the
waiting list i wasn't prepared to see
that waiting has been any higher than it
needs to be i want that waiting list to
be tackled and the way to do it is to
make sure that the resources are there
and they're also making the right
reforms aha now look that's a great
justification but you could be if you're
still health secretary a year from now
and you might want to tell me something
about the reshuffle speculation if you
want you could be coming on here next
year and giving me another great and
smooth reason for why you've changed
your mind let me ask you if you would
give us a commitment you're saying that
you're switching the money into social
care when
the covered emergency allows and waiting
lists allow you to get to somewhere set
a level
is that is that going to happen when uh
waiting lists get back to pre-covered
level let's say for example the level of
2010 when tories came into government of
2.5 million uh would you would you say
that's when social care gets the money
now what i'll say trevor is that you
first of all of the the announcement the
money that we said that will be raised
the total and you're 36 billion yeah
some 5.4 billion of that will be going
to social care no matter what happens
that's going to be going into social
care to support the new cap to support a
more generous means-tested system to
give local councils more support more
workplace training so that's going to go
into social care over time over the sort
of those three years the the the nhs
would have made you know maximum use
huge use in tackling the waiting list
with the money that it will be getting
but also that cap that we've announced
the 86 000 pound cap on lifetime costs
that only sort of starts the bite in
later years you're beyond the three
years and that's why this levy i'm
certain will be able to cover that cost
and those costs in in the years you know
beyond the next uh you know
parliamentary period there's a timing
thing here though let me tell you what
they're saying in local government
they're saying that
when you start spending the money on
social care which is 2023
the money that you've raised
from this new tax will still be going
into the nhs and you know who's going to
have to fill the gap in those three
years
local government
through raising the council tax and what
you will then do is say
we raise the tax but local government
spend thrift they're not doing their
part
you are going to dump this on local
councils aren't you
no no not at all i mean already today
spending on adult social care some in
normal times around 20 billion pounds a
year that's a combination of funding
from central government and locally
raised funds what we've announced this
week is a top-up on that to to provide
as i say the more workplace training
this new system of a cabin and better
means testing so it's a top-up of that
it will remain a combination of funds
and and each year will be determined uh
based on need but the the changes that
we've announced today will make it a
stronger system and and local
authorities will continue to play a
hugely important role in that
okay look um a quick question on
universal credit and you can do this on
in yes and no
are you going to cut universal credit by
20 pounds a week
we're going to end the temporary
increase in universal credit
so the answer yes that cut you're not
budging on that at all
the the the the the increase which was
temporary will be ended as planned at
the end of this month
it's been reported this weekend that the
prime minister reckons that he wants to
stay in downing street for another
decade
well obviously the electorate's going to
decide that but they're going to want to
know
why he wants to stay there and there's a
curious thing here you spend trillions
of public money
you intrude on individual freedom down
to telling us what we can and cannot
wear on our faces and you boast about
defending the most socialist health
system in europe um what exactly is
conservative about the tories right now
well if you look at you talked about the
intrusion of freedom and that you're
right to raise that we should never
intrude on people's freedom uh unless
there was a really really good reason to
do so what we've seen in the last couple
of years is the government respond to a
global emergency respond with the most
successful vaccination program the world
has ever seen
and
and help us get through this very
difficult period including having to
break a manifesto promise to make sure
that we show people just how responsible
and serious this government is about
meeting the people's challenges we've
done that even the the package we've
talked about we've done that in a
responsible way by by being honest and
raising attacks instead of borrowing and
mortgaging the future of the next
generation that's very conservative too
but we are always looking to to make
sure that as a country that we support
businesses we support the economy so it
can continue to grow and there's there's
no doubt as we start to see that growth
now we can create the opportunities that
everyone would expect a conservative
government to do so all right well look
let me let me ask you a question uh
which essentially uh is about whether
you don't come back on here and give me
some more reasons for why you're not
really a tory will you commit to no more
tax rises in this parliament
look i'm not chancellor anymore um if
you get the chance on your show you can
ask him about tax questions what i can
tell you as a conservative and as a
proud member of a conservative
government you know we should always be
trying to keep taxes as low as we
possibly can and and making sure that we
recognize that when you have tax any
type of tax you're taking away
hard-working people's money and every
single penny should be spent wisely all
right let me put this another way then
deal between you
sajid javid and me trevor phillips if
somebody comes forward chancellor prime
minister with a proposal for more tax
rises in this parliament will you
sergeant javid oppose those tax rises
i think we should be if we have to spend
more somewhere else i think that we
should always be trying first to see
where we can make savings to to pay for
that not extra tax rises and tax rise
should always be the last resort it's
been right to do it on this occasion but
we should always uh try to avoid it